big story in the LA Times black people
are fleeing the United States would he
reverse would they reverse oh because of
the oppression and the colonialism and
the imperialism and the ism and the
racism and the ismism lay in the EG Bay
America does not deserve me why black
people are leaving the United States
says the LA Times filmmaker Jamila
nedine always tried to work twice as
hard as those around her thinking if I'm
smart enough pretty enough successful
enough then finally people will treat me
as a human being but she grieved yet
another unarmed black man killed by
police she decided she was done trying
to prove herself to a society that she
felt would never really love her back so
nor Dean 39 packed her bags and left
what was the net movement of black
people into and out of the United States
over the last say 20 years
roughly 3 million into the United States